the mortgage business is a very old
business it's not something that like
young people get into so for me when i
looked at this business i thought a lot
about hey what is the actual execution
model that we need to have in order to
build a long-term business in a way that
is very sustainable
[Music]
i'm andrew wang i'm the ceo of ballen
technologies and i am 29 years old
valen is a mortgage servicing technology
company we're trying to champion
homeowners and make sure that they have
a trusted brand that they can work with
it's a very complicated process today
and what we're trying to do is simplify
it
[Music]
i actually came from the investment side
of the world so i was looking for a
company that i could work with and i
felt really treated borrowers the right
way as well as treated me as a client of
theirs the right way because today the
way it works is that a mortgage
portfolio owner actually has to go
contract with a mortgage servicing
company in order to get their mortgages
serviced so what ended up happening is
as i looked at these companies more and
more i realized that none of them
actually cared about the underlying
consumers which really got me first
looking to find a company to invest in
but i couldn't find anyone who really
wanted to take this mission in this
endeavor which is why i decided to build
this company
it's actually a very difficult space in
general to get started in terms of a
business because it's highly highly
regulated there were two large phases of
difficulties that we ran into the first
phase was actually convincing investors
that this was a doable thing because you
have to do a lot of r d you have to
understand all these regulations and
regulations in this space specifically
is across 50 states so you have to
understand the laws of 50 states as well
as the federal regulations as well as
what's called
agency regulations part two of it was
actually getting business from
enterprises right because again it's a
really regulated space usually they'll
say hey why don't you just work with
so-and-so a large company at least they
are someone who's been around in the
space
so getting past that and getting to a
place where we now are able to service
large quantums of mortgages as well as
work with multiple institutional
partners that took a lot of convincing a
lot of really getting people to buy into
the concept and the long-term viability
of the solution
[Music]